BERTRAND CARIOU: Hello
everyone, and thank you
for joining today's session,
where we'll be covering new use
cases in Cloud
Dataprep, DataPipeline,
and new connectors.
We're super excited to share
what's new for Cloud Dataprep,
and in particular,
two new additions.
A ton of effort--
thousands of hours of
hard work of engineering
have been dedicated--
to realize what we think is
the ultimate and most advanced
data preparation solution
ever designed for the cloud.
I am Bertrand Cariou,
Product Marketing Manager
for Cloud Dataprep.
I have been with Trifacta
for the last five years.
I have a long background working
in the data and analytic space,
as a practitioner and
with software vendors.
I am delighted to co-host
this webinar with Sean Ma,
Product Manager responsible
for Cloud Dataprep.
Sean, you want to quickly
introduce yourself?
SEAN MA: Sure, thanks Bertrand.
Hi, my name is Sean Ma.
I've been with Trifacta
for the last six years.
As Bertrand just said,
I'm the Product Manager
for Cloud Dataprep.
I've been working
with Google Cloud
on this joint product
for many years,
since the very beginning.
Over the last four years,
it's been our privilege
to watch how Dataprep
has grown and helped
solve data challenges
for many types of users,
whether they be data analysts,
engineers, or scientists.
Thanks to tons of
feedback from the users,
we really hope that we've been
able to listen and channel
that feedback into some
of the new capabilities
that you're going to see today.
With that, let's get started.
BERTRAND CARIOU: Thank you.
So here is the agenda
for the next 25 minutes.
We'll be first
covering Cloud Dataprep
Journey, which started four
years ago, as we just said,
Sean.
And we have achieved a
lot through that journey.
Especially we learned new use
cases, such as cloud analytics
modernization, marketing
analytics, pricing
optimization, retails
analytic, [INAUDIBLE]
even manufacturing analytics.
We have released
two new additions
to support all
these new use case,
and Sean Ma will go over
them in the details.
Sean will then go over a
demo so you can see what
the new additions look like.
After a quick
[INAUDIBLE],, this session
will be open for
question that you
can submit through the chat.
Or also, you can request
one-on-one meeting session
with our experts in the
next couple of weeks
after you watch the session.
So let's get started, then.
So before we deep dive
in the new capabilities
and new product, I wanted to
review in a couple of minutes
an overview that will be, for
most of you, maybe, a refresh.
But I wanted to go back to the
background of Cloud Dataprep.
So Dataprep is developed
by Trifacta in partnership
with Google Cloud.
Trifacta as a company
and as a product
is the recognized leader
in data preparation.
Trifacta also offers
solutions that
run on over Cloud platforms.
It runs also on its own
Trifacta SaaS, or on-premise.
So you can really select the
version of the product that
fits your needs.
Cloud Dataprep on
the Google Cloud
is the serverless and only
native to the Google Cloud Data
Preparation solution as part of
the broader Google Cloud Smart
Analytic suites.
Cloud Dataprep allows data
analysts, business analysts,
and engineers and
data scientists
to explore clean and
prepared big data visual.
As you can see on the
left of the screen,
Cloud Dataprep
connects to BigQuery,
Cloud storage, Google
Sheets, as well as
traditional databases
and Cloud apps.
At the center, you can
see that Cloud Dataprep
is built on top of Dataflow.
What it means is that any data
transformation containing rules
that design in Cloud Dataprep
is pushed down to Dataflow
and can easily
scale to transform
any data, big or small.
Now focusing on the right
part of the diagram,
once your data is ready in
BigQuery or Cloud storage,
you can analyze it with Google
Cloud Data Studio or Looker.
You can try enmeshing learning
models with Google Cloud ML
Services, or you
can even get insight
from over a partner
VI Solutions,
such as Qlik or Tableau.
Now if we just focus on
the bottom of the screen,
Cloud Dataprep is a native
services to Google Cloud.
It provides APIs that we can
leverage with other technology,
or Google technologies such
as Cloud Composer, [INAUDIBLE]
APIs to schedule and to
orchestrate Cloud Dataprep,
or leverage Cloud functions.
For example, when a file
arrives in Google Cloud Storage,
you can trigger a
Cloud Dataprep flow.
So this is a summary of an
overview of Cloud Dataprep
and where it fits
in the Google Cloud.
So now, let's get to the
core of this presentation.
Thanks to tremendous adoption
since 2017 by over hundred
of thousand of user,
we're able to capture
requirements for new
and advanced use spaces.
This results in the launch
of two new Cloud Dataprep
editions, the standard edition
and the premium edition,
that support new use
case, more flexibility,
also in the pricing
that we can offer.
So Cloud Dataprep is now based
on fixed project basis pricing,
which you can try for free.
So you can really start
free with Cloud Dataprep
to try out these new features.
You can also get,
now, direct access
to Trifacta support, trainings,
and professional services.
With Cloud Dataprep
Premium, you now
have advanced connectivity
with Google Sheets, databases,
and Cloud applications.
Sean will cover in the
details and demo it.
There is also new DataPipeline
capabilities with brand
new job orchestration workspace,
with task sequencing, alerts,
webhooks, advanced
APIs to integrate
Cloud Dataprep to feed
broader analytic occasions.
And you've got also data
processing optimization
and Dataflow for even
faster performances.
Cloud Dataprep also
gets some options
for fine-grained permissions
and management for end users.
Sean will deep dive
in a few seconds
on all these capabilities.
So Cloud Dataprep Standard
and Premium are available now.
You can see at the
bottom of the screen
the link you should mark.
You just go to the marketplace--
the Google Cloud marketplace--
you search for Trifacta.
You'll find it.
However, Cloud
Dataprep is also still
part of the Google Cloud
Console that we know best.
So you can sign up
on the marketplace
or on the Google Cloud Console.
So now I'll hand it
over to Sean to go over
the details of Dataprep
Standard and Premium.
Sean, it's all yours.
SEAN MA: Sure.
Thanks.
So I'm going to cover
four categories where
Cloud Dataprep is either new
or significantly improved
in both the existing product
as well as the new standard
and premium editions.
So the first area
we're going to cover
is our new self-service
connectors,
which allow us to easily
access all your data
from within Dataprep itself.
While native GCP connectivity
to various sources and targets
has always been there,
you don't always
have your initial
starting point of data
in Cloud Storage or BigQuery.
A common example of
this is Google Sheets,
which businesses use as a
primary method for collecting
and sharing data.
Typically, they want to
combine this data with tables
in BigQuery or standardize it
against files in Cloud Storage.
In this case, Cloud
Dataprep's goal
is to provide the same
familiar search experience
that Google Drive has
to these same users
so they can easily
find and import
that data set
directly into Dataprep
without any additional
configuration.
As a bonus, there is no
limit to the size of data
or the number of Sheets
that you can import.
For example, in cases where
there are new Sheets being
added to a single G-suite
document every day,
you can configure Cloud Dataprep
to automatically pick up
all these new Sheets and add
them to the existing data
source without having to make
any changes to your recipe.
In other cases, users
need quick access
to a handful of
sources typically found
in traditional databases.
So either to do
a lookup or maybe
fetch the latest
delta of data that's
available in the
database itself.
This is where the new
relational connectors,
such as Oracle, SQL
server, [INAUDIBLE],,
just to name a few, come in
handy, as well as application
connectors to
Salesforce, make it easy
for you to grab all
the necessary data
from a single interface by
just simply selecting from one
of the existing connections.
Last but not least,
BigQuery continues
to be the primary source
and target for a majority
of the Dataprep users.
And we continue to
make key improvements
in this area, such as automatic
column filtering, which
is a huge performance
gain, because what it does
is automatically prune
some of the columns
that you aren't
using so you process
less data and the whole
result comes back faster.
On the flexibility side, we
now allow custom SQL data
sets, which means users can
create their own standard SQL
statement, and actually
import that and use
that as a data source itself.
OK.
Let's move on to the next slide.
As users build longer
recipes and continue
to combine more
data sources, we've
seen the size and complexity of
their Dataprep flows increase
dramatically.
Thanks to vocal feedback
from our community,
we've revamped the flow UI
for improved productivity.
Now you can drag and drop
your recipes, your sources,
and even your outputs,
into customized layouts.
And you have easy access
to common transformations
like union or join
directly from the flow.
The addition of email
notifications and webhook tasks
allow you to
configure who and how
you want other users or
services to be alerted when
Dataprep jobs are completed.
This can be configured
to start immediately
after a job has been
completed successfully,
where you can send an email.
Or, in the case of
failure, maybe you
need to notify a
down train system.
Whatever use case
best fits your needs,
we should be able
to support that.
A big development
is the addition
of recipe parameters,
which allow
you to make a recipe
behave dynamically
based on inputs that are
inserted at job execution time.
This is critical for
sharing and reusability,
where one user creates a
common piece of logic that
can be used by many others.
Users can achieve this
by defining recipe steps
with parameters that change
the logic based on the input.
A common example is
financial calculations,
which often need the
latest currency conversion
rates to be passed in
at the time of run.
And so now you can do
that without having
to modify the recipe at all.
And last thing to note, in
order to round out reusability,
we've made it much
easier to import
export flows across projects.
This makes it much easier to
jumpstart a new initiative
by simply migrating a copy
of your flows and recipes
to another user so they
can start getting started
with Dataprep from there.
Flow by itself is
not always enough.
Sometimes you might need to
chain together multiple flows.
Or you need to combine
them with external services
so you can achieve your
end to end use case.
That's why we're introducing
a brand new visual interface,
Cloud Dataprep Plans,
that orchestrate
multiple tasks within Dataprep.
Not only can you visually
design the sequence of tasks,
but you can actually
monitor their execution
status and their outputs.
This comes in handy whenever one
flow depends on a [? Urdia ?]
flow to have run completed.
Or you need to run a command
statement or a SQL statement
before running another flow.
Coming soon, you'll be able
to trigger these plans based
on various external events,
like the arrival of a new file
or an external API call.
Then you can build
conditional logic
to decide which set of tasks
you want to execute next.
We also know that
many users already
have existing data
pipelining tools that
are used in production
today, so we
wanted to provide flexibility
with Cloud Dataprep
to integrate into those
existing workflows.
This is why we've extended
the work we introduced
last year with Cloud Composer
and Dataprep's job execution
APIs by adding brand new APIs
to fetch profiling and recipe
metadata directly from Dataprep.
These APIs were
designed so that you
can leverage key
metrics generated
from the Dataprep job, such as
data quality results, directly
into your external tool
through the same workflow
tool of choice.
OK.
We've got one last
category, but maybe
it's the most important one--
security and governance.
We've seen the adoption
Dataprep grow significantly
across multiple teams
and departments.
As a result, these teams
have higher demands
in terms of their security
and governance requirements
to meet this broader
environment need.
Security has always
been top of mind
with Dataprep,
which is why we've
extended our native
integration with Google IM
to now add fine
grained data access
permissions within
the Dataprep project.
Security has always been
top of mind with Dataprep,
so building on our native
integration with Google IM,
we've added
fine-grained data access
within each Dataprep project.
Now teams can control
individual data set access
through a combination
of Google IM roles,
as well as BigQuery and
Cloud Storage access rights.
This also applies to G Suite,
where you can import sources
like Google Sheets.
Now when a shared Google Sheet
is imported into Dataprep,
the same access rights that
were granted in G Drive
are now applied
within Dataprep, which
means only users who are
authorized to see and prepare
that data are the ones who
are going to access it.
Lastly, networking has
been the other major part
that we've been improving
in terms of security.
And the goal is to
support a much wider range
of configurations
that you've set up
within your IT environment.
This includes custom networks,
private IPs, shared VPCs.
So in the latest edition,
you'll see many new options
that are available when
you run a Cloud Dataprep
job in Dataflow.
You've always been able to
run a job in different regions
from different data
centers around the world.
But in addition to that,
now you can specify things
like a custom VPC network name,
sub network, custom service
names, labels.
And you can even fine
tune some of the execution
parameters for the Dataflow
job itself, such as workers.
OK.
And with that, let's
get into a brief demo
for a few of these
key capabilities
that I just covered.
Start with the new Cloud
Dataprep by Trifacta listing
that's now available
on the GCP Marketplace.
As you can see here, it's
got lots of information
about the two new editions
that are available.
So you can go ahead and
purchase new projects
for standard or
premium or you can
upgrade an existing project.
Once it's purchased, you
can then launch the product
from the left hand nav by
scrolling down to the big data
section and selecting Dataprep.
From there, it'll launch you
directly into the product,
and you can see which
edition you have
based on the logo up above.
In this case, it's premium.
Now what I'd like to do is
actually take an existing flow
and augment it with some of the
new capabilities we just talked
about in the presentation today.
So with that, I'm going to
click on this particular flow,
Customer Activity and
Retention, and open it.
Inside, you'll see
this flow here,
which has got existing
recipe and output.
In this case, it's got
an Oracle source, which
is taking accounts
activity data,
and then it's running a recipe
that cleanses activity data
and outputting it
out to BigQuery.
What I want to do is
augment this recipe
with data from Google Sheets.
In this case, I've got
account contact information
in Google Sheets.
Here, you've got various columns
and information inside of that.
What I'd like to do
as a part of this
is make sure that
the data is cleansed
and I can capture
all the data inside.
You'll see here that I've
got multiple Sheets of data--
Week 1 followed by Week 2.
So that's what I
want to pull in.
And just to make sure that
everything is up to date,
I'm going to go ahead and just
make a quick modification here.
Make that change.
So I now know this is
the latest one that's
been saved to my drive.
OK.
Let's go back to Cloud Dataprep.
Now, I add this to my flow.
I click on Add.
You can see here
all the various data
sources that are supported.
GCS, Google Sheets, BigQuery,
and several relational systems
that are now available.
Click on Google Sheets.
I typed in part of the name
inside there, July 2020.
Boom.
The account contact info, the
one I just modified just now,
is available.
So I can go ahead
and import that.
I'll just click there.
It's importing into this.
So it's doing two things.
One, it's checking to make sure
I have the right permissions
and right access for this.
In this case, it's mine,
so that should be easy.
And it's also making sure
that it captures both Sheets.
In this case, the
two Sheets there.
As in this case, two
separate data sets.
During data set creation, I
chose, instead of making them
two separate data sets,
I want to combine them
into one data set.
This is handy if you have more
Sheets coming in in the future.
So now it's acting
as one data set.
I'm going to hit
Save, and now I'm
going to import
that into my flow.
OK.
Now we've got that data
set imported in my flow.
You can see the
details inside of this.
I want to combine it.
I can do that easily by
just clicking Append Join
to this particular recipe.
Now what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to make sure that I'm selecting
the correct data set to join.
In this case,
account contact info.
I'm going to hit Accept.
And it's going to go
ahead and join to this.
I'm going through skip
through a couple of steps
just to make this demo
go a little faster.
But now that it's successfully
joined, I can see it there.
Just for ease of
understanding, I'm
going to reposition this so it
lines up with my other sources.
All right.
So now, for the most part,
I've got most of the data
that I want inside this.
Let me go check my output.
Yeah.
I've got a destination that I've
correctly set, in this case,
to BigQuery.
And I want to add an action
after this particular job is
completed running.
In this case, I am
interested in kicking off
a Cloud function that
will analyze the output
from a successful job run.
To do this, I will go
ahead and add a new webhook
task that executes after
the job is complete.
Let's take a quick look
at the Cloud function
by pulling it up.
It's a simple function
that calls a scoring
model against account data.
I'll quickly grab the trigger
for that particular account
scoring model, take that,
and I'll go back to Dataprep.
So now when I create
a webhook task,
I can give it a quick
name, Account Scoring.
And I will just paste
the exact same URL
that I got from the trigger.
I'll choose that I
want this to happen
on job success on any
particular output.
And finally, I'll
pass in the headers.
Let's go ahead and
test that first.
Just make sure it's working.
OK good.
I triggered it against
Cloud functions.
I'll hit Create.
There.
Now I have my
webhook task there.
Let's finish this off by
actually running the job.
You can see here,
in the run job view,
you can choose to
profile your results,
again checking
that I'm outputting
to the right location.
Then I'll set the correct
region that I'm running from.
In this case, I'm saying I'm
going to run from Europe.
So I'm [? searching ?]
my data centers
and which machines
I'm interested in.
Now it's showing you
the new capabilities
that we added, like customizing
your VPC network mode.
If you want to choose
private IP addresses,
and if you want to go further
and set your auto scaling
algorithms, you can
inside here as well.
That all looks good.
Then I click Run Job.
And with that, the job
should be kicking off.
As a recap of this
scenario, this job
will read data from
Oracle and Google Sheets,
join them in a single
recipe, and cleanse the data.
The output will be
sent to BigQuery
and a Cloud function
will be triggered
to run a scoring
algorithm on that data
once that job has
completed successfully.
BERTRAND CARIOU: Thanks,
Sean for walking us
through the demo.
That was a pretty
comprehensive demo,
and it give us a pretty good
idea of what Cloud Dataprep
Premium can offer.
To summarize, and
before we wrap up,
here is what is new
with Cloud Dataprep.
First, Cloud Dataprep now
comes in two editions.
So you get the standard
edition, the premium edition.
And on the right, you can
see all these capabilities
from a high level perspective
and [INAUDIBLE] the ones
from Premium.
Secondly, Cloud Dataprep
now offers a fixed project
based pricing, OK?
So you define the number
of projects you want,
and you get a
pricing per project.
However, you can still
start free Cloud Dataprep.
In addition to the
Google Cloud Console,
where you are used to start
and sign up for Cloud Dataprep,
we now have an option to
sign up for Cloud Dataprep
from the Google
Cloud Marketplace,
and it offers more flexibility
to customize the pricing based
on your usage, such as
the number of projects,
or if you want annual
or multiyear up
front subscriptions.
You get also additional
direct access
to the Trifacta support,
direct connection
with experts in Cloud Dataprep.
Last but not least, you can
get specialized training
and services packages to get
your data preparation teams
and project on track for fast
and successful [INAUDIBLE]..
With all these
editions, Cloud Dataprep
is getting to a really new
level of excellence to make
sure you can convert
all your data
preparation initiatives with
the flexibility [? you need. ?]
So, before we close up, I
wanted to give a few links
that you should try.
And in particular, we've
got a good white paper
about five lessons we learned
to adopt self-service analytics
in the Cloud.
So you'll get to
understand the end
to end Google Cloud
Smart Analytics
platform and how to make
[INAUDIBLE] big data initiative
or data [INAUDIBLE] and
where Dataprep plays a role,
and how you need to follow a few
tips to really be successful.
Sean, I wanted to thank you
for presenting with me today.
SEAN MA: Yeah,
thank you, Bertrand.
BERTRAND CARIOU: OK.
And thank you,
everyone, for attending.
Stay safe everyone.
Thank you and goodbye.
SEAN MA: Bye everyone.